This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《硬核学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全却又极其坦诚的对话，而你正在与一位持证专业人士一起交流
who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
他深知自己在做什么。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须这样做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《硬核学习》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
你曾对某人的这份特定检测报告做过两次手脚，对吗？我只对检测动过一次手脚。数以万计的互联网侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
这是《被爱捕获》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被爱捕获》播客。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是数字2开头的百分之二。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. I am so glad that you are here. Thank you for tuning in.
请收听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折点，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎新老听众回到本播客，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。我非常高兴你能来到这里。谢谢你的收听。
Thank you for joining us for another episode of The Psychology of Your 20s. This week, we're going to talk about something that is highly personal to me at the moment and something that I've never spoken about on the show before, despite it being a massive part of my value set, despite it being a massive belief of mine, a massive ethos, and that is why we should take risks in our 20s, why it is so important to step out of our comfort zone, to push the boundaries of what we think we are capable of,
感谢你收听又一期的《你二十岁的心理学》。本周，我们要谈论一件目前对我来说非常私人的事情，也是我在节目中从未谈论过的事情，尽管它是我的价值观体系中极其重要的一部分，尽管它是我深信不疑的信念和精神内核——那就是为什么我们在二十多岁时应该去冒险，为什么跳出舒适区、突破我们自认为能力的边界是如此重要，
to just see what happens, to explore the possibilities that this life and this earth and this decade really provides us. This has been really on my mind recently. For those of you who don't know, I don't do this podcast full time. I have a job. I have a full-time job. I work 9 to 5 in an office.
去看看会发生什么，去探索这个生活、这个地球以及这个十年真正为我们提供的可能性。这最近一直在我的脑海里盘旋。对于那些不知道的人，我并不是全职做这个播客的。我有一份工作。我有一份全职工作。我在办公室朝九晚五地工作。
And that was until recently. I have quit my job. I resigned. And it has really made me rethink my relationship with risk. and reinforce how important it is to take advantage of the opportunity that this decade provides. And that is to make mistakes. That is to really go out into the world and try as many things as possible. And I think it's important to note that it's not just me saying this from a personal perspective,
直到最近还是这样。我已经辞掉了工作。我辞职了。这真的让我重新思考了我与风险的关系。并巩固了利用这个十年所提供的机遇是多么重要。那就是去犯错。那就是真正走到世界出去，尽可能多地尝试各种事情。我认为值得指出的是，这不仅仅是我从个人角度这么说，
but so much of the psychology and the science and the unconscious explanations that science provides us really justifies this and it justifies this pattern of behaviour to take control of your 20s and use it and use this time and use these opportunities to take risks and see what's out there. I think it's such a valuable decade for many reasons. One of them being that our 20s are so unique in that the only person we're normally and I would say usually only accountable to is ourselves. We don't have children. Most of us don't have mortgages. There are no looming responsibilities, I would say, for most of us. Of course, there are instances in which people, you know, get houses young, or they have financial debt from taking out student loans, or they need to look after
而且科学所提供的许多心理学、科学以及无意识的解释，真正地证明了这一点，它证明了这种行为模式：掌控你的二十多岁，利用好这段时间和这些机会去冒险，去看看外面的世界。我认为这是一个非常宝贵的十年，原因有很多。其中之一就是我们的二十多岁是如此独特，通常情况下——我可以说通常——我们只需要对自己负责。我们没有孩子。我们大多数人没有房贷。我想，对我们大多数人来说，没有什么迫在眉睫的责任。当然，也有一些情况下，人们很年轻就买了房子，或者因为申请学生贷款而负债累累，或者他们需要照顾
a parent who was ill. But I would say in general, this decade is defined. It is characterized by freedom. So I really want to explore that today and I really want to encourage people through this podcast, through what I'm going to speak on, to take risks, to embrace being uncomfortable in this decade, to embrace the unknown. I want to talk about why it's absolutely crucial that during this decade we embrace the opportunity of freedom. We embrace the opportunity of being, I think, not tied down. We're going to talk about identity, about unbounded versus bounded risk, existential dread as your friend rather than your enemy, and about regret and how the psychology of regret actually should compel us to take risks rather than avoid them. like I said it's just such a pertinent topic for me it's just so crazy how life works out you know the job that I was previously working was my dream job it was the thing that I always thought that I wanted and it kind of got to a point where I realized it wasn't my dream anymore doing this show full time
生病的父母。但我想总的来说，这个十年的定义是这样的。它的特征就是自由。所以我今天真的很想探讨这一点，我真的很想通过这个播客，通过我要讲的内容，来鼓励大家去冒险，在这个十年里拥抱不适，拥抱未知。我想谈谈为什么在这个十年里，拥抱自由的机会是绝对至关重要的。我们拥抱这种——我认为是没有被束缚的——机会。我们将讨论身份认同、有界与无界风险、存在主义焦虑作为你的朋友而非敌人，以及关于遗憾，以及遗憾的心理学实际上应该促使我们去冒险而不是逃避它。就像我说的，这对我来说是一个非常贴切的话题，生活的发展方式真是太疯狂了，你知道的，我以前做的那份工作曾是我的梦想工作。它是我一直以为自己想要的东西，然后它达到了一个点，我意识到它不再是我的梦想了。全职做这个节目，
being able to have amazing conversations with people using this platform that was my dream and life changes in an instant and sometimes you need to really have the courage to grasp and grab and cling on to the opportunities that life throws you. I also think that because of the pandemic, because of COVID, a lot of us in our 20s lost valuable years to lockdown and to this disease that was running rampant across the globe and wanting to be safe. And we've had this realization that we've lost valuable years, valuable years of our 20s that we want to make up. And part of that is a reframing of our narrative and our perspective towards our lives to be more risk-taking. So I really want to discuss and I want to break down all of the psychology, all of the science behind why it is that we should take risks in our 20s.
能够与人们进行精彩的对话，利用这个平台，那才是我的梦想。生活在瞬间发生改变，有时你真的需要有勇气去抓住、紧紧依附生活抛给你的机会。我也认为，由于大流行，由于新冠疫情，我们许多二十多岁的人在封锁和这种在全球肆虐且人们渴望安全的疾病中失去了宝贵的几年。我们意识到我们已经失去了宝贵的几年，我们二十多岁时想要弥补的宝贵的几年。这其中的一部分就是重构我们的叙事和对生活的视角，变得更有冒险精神。所以我真的很想讨论并剖析所有这些心理学和科学背后的原理，即为什么我们应该在二十多岁时冒险。
I think a huge part of our 20s, a huge job that we have to do in this decade, is figuring out who we are, figuring out what we want from our lives, figuring out our identity. And that doesn't always come easy. I think previously in past decades and past generations, it was very easy to look at our lives in a very linear sense. You know, we graduated high school, maybe we went to university, we met someone that we wanted to have kids with, we bought a home, we had children with them, we worked until the age of 65, and then we retired and we were kind of done. And it's really interesting that a lot of people are pushing back against that narrative and pushing back against that conventional, traditional way of going about life. and part of that reaction and part of that pattern of behavior that we're seeing more of is a propensity to take risk.
我认为我们二十多岁时很大的一部分工作，我们在十年来必须完成的一项重大任务，就是弄清楚我们是谁，弄清楚我们对生活有什么诉求，弄清楚我们的身份认同。这并不总是那么容易。我认为在过去的几十年和过去的世代中，以非常线性的方式看待生活是非常容易的。你知道的，我们高中毕业，也许上了大学，遇到了一个我们想和他/她生孩子的人，我们买了一栋房子，和他们生了孩子，我们工作到65岁，然后我们退休了，基本上就完成了。非常有趣的是，很多人都在反抗这种叙事，反抗这种传统、常规的生活方式。而这种反应以及我们看到的越来越多这种行为模式的一部分，就是一种冒险的倾向。
More individuals are putting themselves out there and doing things that I think previously would have been not so much unacceptable but risky and would have been seen as a bit dangerous. And those decisions have become a lot more common and a lot more popular. It's so interesting to me to think about the people, in my life to think about the friends that I have who have made the leap who have made the decision to do things in an untraditional way who have decided to travel who have decided to put off going to uni and do something do something different to explore their passions and to move to different cities and different countries just to see what it's like
更多的人开始展现自我，做一些我认为在过去可能不仅是不被接受，而且是有风险、被视为有点危险的事情。这些决定变得越来越普遍，也越来越受欢迎。思考我生活中的那些人、我那些勇敢跨出这一步、决定以非传统方式做事的朋友，对我来说非常有趣：他们决定去旅行，决定推迟上大学去做点别的、做点不同的事情来探索自己的激情，并搬到不同的城市和不同的国家，只是为了看看那是什么样的。
I think that those decisions are so valuable during this decade. I talk about this a lot on the show, but the reason why our 20s are so formative and so important is it's because when a lot of our identity is established. Our brain does not fully develop until the age of 25. So that early part of our 20s, especially for the people between the ages of 20 and 20, and 25, that period is when your brain is still developing and your brain is still fully forming to create the person that you are going to become. Part of that development is making decisions that you think are going to best impact your life. Those decisions, like I said, are not always
我认为这些决定在这个十年里是非常宝贵的。我在节目中经常谈到这一点，但为什么我们的二十多岁如此具有塑造性且如此重要，原因在于我们的许多身份正是在这时确立的。我们的大脑直到25岁才完全发育成熟。所以在我们二十多岁的早期，特别是对于20岁到25岁之间的人来说，那个时期正是你的大脑仍在发育、仍在完全成型以塑造未来的你的时期。这种发展的一部分就是做出你认为会对你的生活产生最好影响的决定。正如我所说，这些决定并不总是
going to be easy. This decade, and I think especially this generation, has been afforded with so many more opportunities. We talked about this a couple of weeks ago about choice overload and about kind of being paralyzed by the decisions that we have to make in this decade. But often, some of those decisions will involve risk. And that risk is sometimes calculated to be bringing us the best reward. When it comes to kind of weighing up the benefits versus the costs of a risk, of a risk that we want to take, there is this idea of utilitarianism that I think is really valuable. It's used and talked about a lot in philosophy, but I do think it still is really important when we talk about the psychology of our 20s. Essentially, the idea is that our brain will come to the most
那么容易。这个十年，尤其是这一代人，被赋予了更多的机会。我们在几周前讨论过选择过载，以及在十年中必须做出的决定而感到不知所措。但通常情况下，其中一些决定会涉及风险。这种风险有时经过计算，能带给我们最好的回报。当权衡风险的收益与成本、权衡我们想要承担的风险时，有一个功利主义的概念我认为非常有价值。它在哲学中被广泛使用和讨论，但我确实认为当我们谈论二十多岁的心理学时，它仍然非常重要。本质上，这个观点是，我们的大脑会通过评估风险与回报或成本与效益，来为我们做出最
logical and rational decision for us based on an assessment of risk versus reward or cost versus benefit. It's something to really consider, especially when we talk about making grand and exciting and risky decisions in our 20s. For example, deciding to quit your job to pursue your passion. Our brain will sometimes do this unconscious equation based on its own assessment of risk in which it will weigh up the rewards or the expected benefits versus the costs versus kind of the risk, essentially. And it's really interesting because there are people who
合乎逻辑和理性的决定。这是真正需要考虑的事情，特别是在我们谈论在二十多岁时做出宏大、激动人心且充满风险的决定时。例如，决定辞职去追求你的激情。我们的大脑有时会根据其对风险的评估，进行这种无意识的方程式计算，其中它会权衡回报或预期的好处与成本，以及本质上的风险。非常有趣的是，有些人
will look at a situation and their brains will automatically be risk adverse. Essentially what this means is that they are less likely to take a risk. They are more likely to focus on the potential consequences or the potential downsides versus the potential reward. There are also people who are risk positive. This is the friend that you know who is always moving to a new city, is always prepared to quit their job at the click of a finger, always prepared to move homes, to travel the world, to do something that I think normally a lot of us would feel scared to do
会审视一种情况，而他们的大脑会自动表现出风险厌恶。这本质上意味着他们不太可能承担风险。他们更有可能关注潜在的后果或潜在的负面影响，而不是潜在的回报。也有些人是风险偏好型（risk positive）。这就是你认识的那个总是搬到新城市的朋友，总是准备在弹指间辞职，总是准备搬家、环游世界、做一些我认为通常我们中的许多人会感到害怕的事情，
and would be, I think, hesitant to undertake. And then, of course, there are people who are risk neutral. who would see things, I would say quite objectively. They weigh up the risks versus the rewards pretty evenly. And it's interesting to think about the people in our lives and the decisions that they make on this spectrum of risk adverse, risk neutral and risk positive. It doesn't matter where you sit on this spectrum. Maybe you're thinking about those descriptions and being like, oh, I'm someone who's really
并且会犹豫是否要去承担。然后，当然，也有一些风险中立（risk neutral）的人，他们会相当客观地看待事物。他们相当平均地权衡风险与回报。思考我们生活中的人以及他们在风险厌恶、风险中立和风险偏好这个光谱上做出的决定，是非常有趣的。无论你在这个光谱的什么位置，这都无关紧要。也许你正在思考这些描述，然后觉得，哦，我是一个非常
risk adverse. This episode doesn't really relate to me because I'm not. someone who likes to partake in risky behavior. But I do genuinely think that that doesn't really matter, that it's not a question of determination. Regardless of where you sit on the spectrum of propensity to take risk, you can still be someone who is able to push themselves out of their comfort zone and it was able to grasp onto opportunities that may be scary, that may be terrifying, but also could potentially change your life. I love talking about the benefits of pushing yourself beyond where you are comfortable.
风险厌恶的人。这集节目其实跟我没多大关系，因为我不是一个喜欢参与冒险行为的人。但我真心认为这其实并不重要，这并不是一个由性格决定的问题。无论你在这个冒险倾向的光谱上处于什么位置，你依然可以成为一个能够将自己推出舒适区、能够抓住那些可能吓人、可能令人恐惧但也有可能改变你生活的人。我很喜欢谈论将自己推向舒适区之外的好处。
And I don't mean in the sense of allowing people to cross your boundaries or pushing yourself to the point where you're in danger or where you're scared. But I see it more as this bubble, right? Where we sit in this very secluded and I would say central and contained zone of being comfortable. And comfortability is amazing, but you cannot grow whilst being comfortable. It's just not possible because you're not providing your brain or your identity or just your general self with the opportunities to challenge yourself and therefore grow. Taking a risk that may potentially turn out bad, it may potentially blow up in your face
我指的不是允许别人越界，也不是把自己逼到处于危险或害怕的境地。我更多地将它视为一个气泡，对吧？我们坐在一个非常隐蔽、可以说是中央且受控的舒适区里。舒适感太棒了，但你在舒适的同时是无法成长的。这是不可能的，因为你没有为你的大脑、你的身份或你的整体自我提供挑战自我并因此成长机会。承担一个最终可能会变糟的风险，它可能会在你的脸上爆炸，
whatever you think the worst catastrophic outcome is, it could also turn out incredibly well. You could end up making the best decision of your life, not just on a whim, but in the face of all caution. And it's something I do genuinely believe in. The times in my life where I've grown the most, where I've seen the greatest changes in myself, in the quality of my life, in the quality of my relationships in my overall happiness have been after the periods where I've experienced the greatest fear because I've been willing and I've forced myself to approach the unknown and not be scared of it but excited. There is an idea here that I really want to talk about and it's the idea of existential dread. We've talked about this before and I know that people will be thinking
无论你认为最糟糕的灾难性结果是什么，它也可能结果好得不可思议。你最终可能会做出你一生中最好的决定，不仅仅是一时冲动，而是在面对所有警惕时做出的。这确实是我真心相信的事情。在我生命中成长最多、看到自己发生最大改变的时期，在我生活质量、人际关系质量以及整体幸福感发生最大变化的时期，都是在我经历最大恐惧之后的那些时期，因为我愿意并且强迫自己去接近未知，而不是害怕它，而是为之兴奋。这里有一个我真的很想谈论的想法，那就是存在主义焦虑的概念。我们以前讨论过这个，我知道人们会想，
extracental dread is really scary. It's about contemplating our mortality, how we are finite, how we really only have limited time on this earth. It's about contemplating the fact that we will die and questioning our meaning and our place in this world. I think that's one perspective. We can approach the finality of our life with fear, but it is also an incredible and enabler and an incredible motivator towards taking that risk, taking a leap of faith. We can consider the fact that we are all only on this planet for a limited amount of time, that our purpose is not always provided to us, it's not always easy to understand, that death is inevitable, and that realization can be really scary.
存在主义焦虑真的很可怕。它是关于思考我们的必死性，我们是如何有限的，我们在地球上的时间 realmente 真的只有有限的。它是关于思考我们将要死亡的事实，并质疑我们在世界上的意义和位置。我认为这是一种视角。我们可以带着恐惧来对待我们生命的有限性，但它也是促使我们承担风险、信仰之跃的一个令人难以置信的赋能因素和巨大的激励因素。我们可以考虑到这样一个事实：我们所有人在这个星球上都只有有限的时间，我们的目标并不总是提供给我们，它并不总是容易理解，死亡是不可避免的，这种认识可能会非常可怕。
That's existential dread. and as someone who has experienced that, I know how terrible it can be and how consuming and overwhelming and exhausting it can be. But something that I realized is that by flipping that narrative, we can actually be excited by the prospect that what we do in this life really doesn't matter. And I know it's kind of depressing to suggest that and maybe a bit demoralizing, but what you do on this earth, it really doesn't matter. really doesn't matter. And isn't that the most liberating idea, the most liberating thought you can have? Because no matter how many mistakes you make, no matter how many risks you take that don't work out in your favor, the end is still going to be the end. We're all going to end up in the same place. So why not just take the risk? Why not just do it? You literally have nothing to lose.
这就是存在主义焦虑。作为一个经历过这一切的人，我知道它有多糟糕，它可以是多么消耗、压倒性和精疲力竭。但我意识到的一点是，通过扭转这种叙事，我们其实可以对这样一种前景感到兴奋：我们在这一生中所做的事情其实根本不重要。我知道暗示这一点听起来有点沮丧，也许有点消极，但在地球上你所做的事情，真的不重要。真的不重要。难道这不是最令人解放的想法，你所能拥有的最令人解放的想法吗？因为无论你犯了多少错误，无论你冒了多少对你不利的风险，结局依然会是结局。我们最终都会走到同一个地方。那为什么不直接去冒险呢？为什么不直接去做呢？你真的没有什么可失去的，
genuinely nothing. And I find that when I think about my life choices in that sense, it makes it so much easier to make a decision that I am often very happy about in the future. I think essentially what I'm trying to say is that existential dread can be really scary, but it's also about perspective. And this whole episode is about why you should take risks in your 20s. And if you're listening to this thinking, you know, there's something that I really want to do. There's this risk that I really want to take. I really want to go and travel. I really want to text this person who I think that I like, and I want to see if they're interested in me. I really want to go and pursue my dreams. There is no reason why you shouldn't do that. There is absolutely none because your life is short,
真的什么都没有。我发现，当我以这种方式思考我的人生选择时，这让我更容易做出一个我在未来通常会非常高兴的决定。我想我真正想说的是，存在主义焦虑可能真的很可怕，但它也关乎视角。整集节目都是关于为什么你应该在二十多岁时冒险。如果你听了这些并在想，你知道的，有件事我真的很想做。我真的很想冒这个险。我真的很想去旅行。我真的很想给这个我觉得我喜欢的人发短信，我想看看他/她对我有没有兴趣。我真的很想去追求我的梦想。你没有任何理由不去做这件事。绝对没有，因为你的生命很短暂，
but your life is also valuable. And you are in charge of your destiny. If you take a risk and it fails, you're going to be in the exact same place at the end of the day as you will be if you didn't take that risk. We're all going to end up in the same place. But the thing that will be different is your quality of life. And the thing that will be different is your acknowledgement and your recognition that you gave it a go, that you tried it, that you were confident enough, that you are willing enough to really invest in yourself and invest in the idea of what could have been and what will be.
但你的生命也很有价值。你是你命运的主宰。如果你冒险失败了，到头来你还是会处在和不冒险时完全一样的地方。我们最终都会走到同一个地方。但会有所不同的是你的生活质量。会有所不同的是你的认可和承认：你尝试过了，你努力过了，你足够自信，你愿意真正投资于自己，投资于曾经可能发生的事情和将要发生的事情的想法。
I think this really links to the idea of regret. Regret is something that I think we are all naturally very fearful of. And when we think about our future, we really don't want it to be defined by regretting the decisions that we've made. As humans, we are naturally opposed to uncomfortable and negative feelings. Regret is a pretty profound and negative feeling. So we have evolutionarily and innately become a species that wants to avoid situations in which we will experience this feeling, in which we will look back at our decisions and regret them. But regret is a really complex reaction and a complex emotion. Essentially, it's an emotional state that involves blaming ourselves for a bad outcome, feeling a sense of loss at what might have been.
我认为这真的与遗憾的概念联系在一起。遗憾是我认为我们所有人天生都非常害怕的一件事。当我们思考未来时，我们真的不希望它被我们做出的决定的遗憾所定义。作为人类，我们天生排斥不舒服和负面的感觉。遗憾是一种相当深刻且负面的感觉。因此，我们在进化上和天生上已经成为一个希望避免这种情况的物种——在这些情况下我们会体验到这种感觉，我们会回顾我们的决定并感到后悔。但遗憾是一个非常复杂的反应和复杂的情绪。本质上，它是一种情感状态，涉及将糟糕的结果归咎于自己，对可能发生的事情感到一种失落感，
been or really wishing that we could undo previous choices that we've made. When I talk to people about why they should take that risk, why it's important that they put themselves out there, that they push themselves beyond their comfort zone, a big thing that I often hear is, what if I regret it? What if at the age of 70 I look back at the decisions I've made in my life and I'm filled with regret? It's so interesting, to me that we can fear the potential emotional reaction that we may have to our current choices. Because I just think that is so multifaceted. Like the fact that not only are we worried about our future, but we're worried about how we're
或者真心希望我们能撤销以前做过的选择。当我与人们谈论为什么要承担风险、为什么他们将自己展现出来、将自己推向舒适区之外是如此重要时，我经常听到的一大句话是：“如果我后悔了怎么办？”如果在70岁时，我回顾自己一生中做过的决定，并且充满了遗憾，该怎么办？对我来说，这太有趣了，我们竟然会害怕我们可能对当前选择产生的潜在情感反应。因为我只是觉得这太复杂了。就像不仅我们担心我们的未来，我们还担心我们
going to feel in our future, there is no way of knowing that. And there's no way of knowing whether the decision that you want to make is going to lead to regret or whether it's going to lead to gratefulness and a sense of thankfulness that we did what we did, that we made the decisions that we did. I think regret, although painful to experience, can also be a helpful emotion, particularly when we're young. The pain of regret can really help us refocus and understand exactly what we want from our lives and what we want to do. Because essentially it's our value system reacting to our decisions. It's our value set telling us, don't like where we are. I don't like the decision that we made for whatever reason, and I'm going
未来会有什么感觉，这是无法预知的。而且也没有办法知道你想做出的决定是会导致遗憾，还是会导致感激之情，以及对我们做了我们所做的事情、做了我们所做的决定的一种庆幸。我认为遗憾，尽管经历起来很痛苦，但也可以是一种有用的情绪，特别是当我们还年轻的时候。遗憾带来的痛苦确实能帮助我们重新聚焦，并准确理解我们对生活的要求以及我们想要做什么。因为本质上，这是我们的价值观对我们决定的反应。这是我们的价值观在告诉我们：我不喜欢我们所处的位置。无论出于什么原因，我不喜欢我们做出的决定，我将对此
to react against that. But the thing is that every time we challenge the way we think and we see the world, every time we challenge our value set, we reinforce it. And we're better able to understand exactly what we want from our lives and why we make the decisions that we do. Interestingly, I want to look at this study and I want to talk about this study that looked at regret. Importantly, looked at people who had made risky decisions who had taken a risk at some point in their life compared to those who hadn't. And not only those who hadn't, but those who had been provided with the opportunity at some stage in their life to take the road less travelled, to do something that was unconventional. Essentially, it looked at both these groups and it measured their level of
作出反应。但事实是，每次我们挑战我们的思维方式和看待世界的方式时，每次我们挑战我们的价值观时，我们都在强化它。并且我们能够更好地准确理解我们对生活的要求以及我们为什么要做这些决定。有趣的是，我想看这项研究，我想谈谈这项关于遗憾的研究。重要的是，它研究了那些在生命中的某个阶段做过冒险决定、冒过险的人，与那些没有这样做过的人的对比。不仅是那些没有这样做的人，还有那些在生命中的某个阶段有机会选择人迹罕至的路、做一些非传统事情的人。本质上，它研究了这两组人，并测量了他们在这个充满风险的情况、在这个决定方面的
regret in regards to this risky situation, in regards to this decision. And what it found, I think is incredibly compelling and incredibly persuasive as to why we should take risks in our 20s. Essentially, what they realized was that you are more likely to regret the things you do not do than the actions you do take. Amongst these individuals, the people who actually displayed the highest levels of regret were the ones who didn't do anything about their dreams. It was the people who were inactive, the people who didn't make a decision. Whereas the people who did take a risk, who did decide to go out on their own or do something that was unconventional or untraditional, they were the ones who were not only happiest, but displayed the least amount
遗憾水平。我发现，它所揭示的结果我认为是令人难以置信的引人注目，也极其具有说服力，说明了为什么我们应该在二十岁时冒险。本质上，他们意识到的是：你更有可能后悔的是你没有做的事，而不是你实际采取的行动。在这些个体中，实际上表现出最高水平遗憾的人，恰恰是没有为他们的梦想采取任何行动的人。正是那些不作为的人，那些没有做出决定的人。而那些真正冒了险、决定特立独行或做一些非传统、非正统事情的人，他们不仅是最快乐的，而且表现出的
of regret. And I think that is the most persuasive argument we can make. When we talk about the psychology behind why we should take risks in our 20s, we can learn so much from the people that have come before us. And this study shows that most of the time, it's the people who didn't take the risk that are the ones who experience the most long-term, unpleasant emotional outcomes. Of course, that doesn't mean that you should take every risk that comes across your and that you should do anything that you desire and act on a whim, there are obviously some risks that are more calculated or more conservative or practical than others. And there are some that are just plain ridiculous. Like it's a risk to jump out of a plane having never skydived before. That's not a
遗憾最少。我认为这是最具说服力的论点。当我们谈论为什么我们应该在二十岁时冒险背后的心理学时，我们可以从在我们之前的人身上学到很多东西。这项研究表明，大多数时候，是那些没有冒险的人，经历了最多的长期的、令人不愉快的情感后果。当然，这并不意味着你应该承担遇到的每一个风险，也不意味着你应该随心所欲、凭一时冲动行事。显然，有些风险比其他风险更经过计算、更保守或更务实。还有一些简直荒谬透顶。比如从从未跳过伞的飞机上跳下来，这就是一种风险。这不是一个
smart risk, right? It's not one that is practical. But there are some risks that we would call bounded. Bounded risks are great. The idea is that these type of risks, they have limited downsides, but an unbounded upside. So essentially what that means is that it might cost you up front. You know, you might have to invest time or money or potentially lose out on things like other opportunities. But there is no ceiling on the potential upside. Essentially, what that means is that although there is limited costs, you know, that will be incurred, such as having to quit your job or having to give up on other opportunities or invest a certain amount of time to get this idea off the ground,
明智的风险，对吧？这不是一个务实的风险。但有些风险我们可以称之为有界风险（bounded risks）。有界风险很棒。这个想法是，这类风险具有有限的下行风险，但有无限的上行空间。所以本质上这意味着它可能会让你付出前期成本。你知道的，你可能不得不投入时间或金钱，或者可能失去其他机会等事情。但潜在的上行空间是没有上限的。本质上，这意味着尽管会有有限的成本，你知道的，这些成本将不得不产生，比如不得不辞职或不得不放弃其他机会，或者投入一定的时间让这个想法起步，
the benefit is that there is no limit on the benefit. These are the risks that you should take. I think about it in terms of this podcast, right? when I began it, I did have to invest some time in buying a microphone and setting up a platform and creating these episodes. But there was unlimited benefit, unlimited benefit that came from being able to do something that I loved and engage with people and share and converse and really follow my passion. In contrast, there are these ideas of unbounded risks. These are not so great. They're actually pretty, pretty terrible and not something
但好处是，这种好处是没有限制的。这些就是你应该承担的风险。我用这个播客来思考这个问题，对吧？自我开始它以来，我确实不得不投入一些时间来购买麦克风、建立平台和制作这些节目。但随之而来的是无限的好处，能够做我喜欢的事情、与人互动、分享和交流并真正追随我的激情，从而带来了无限的好处。相比之下，还有无界风险（unbounded risks）的概念。这些就没那么好了。它们实际上非常、非常糟糕，不是我建议我们大多数人去承担的风险。这些风险对于你可能失去多少没有限制。所以与有界风险相比，在有界风险中你可以控制你失去多少，而无界风险是没有限制的。所以无论潜在的回报是多少——它不是无限的——这意味着你可能会失去一些非常宝贵的东西。我喜欢用从从未跳过伞的飞机上跳下来这个想法。在这种情况下，你可能会失去多少是没有限制的，这个限制就是你死，限制就是你的生命。而回报并不是那么大。因此，当我们从我们之前讨论过的功利主义概念或成本效益分析的角度来思考它时，成本大大超过了效益。所以在我们二十多岁时思考我们对待风险的方法时，保持理性是很重要的。
that I advise many of us to take. These risks have no limit to how much you could potentially lose. So compared to bounded risks in which really you get to control how much you lose, unbounded risks, there is no limit. So no matter what the potential payoff, which is not unlimited, it means that you're probably going to lose out on something pretty valuable. I'd like to use this idea of jumping out of a plane having never skydived before. There is no limit to how much you could potentially lose in this situation, the limit being that you die, the limit being your life. And the payoff is not that great. So when we think about it from that idea of utilitarianism that we were talking about before or from a cost-benefit analysis, the costs greatly outweigh the benefits. So it's important to be rational when we think about our approach to taking risks in our 20s.
当然，我认为这个播客和我一直在谈论的内容是非常风险积极的。我真的相信，最惊人的成长将来自于——那些最不舒服的时期，我们真正把自己推到极限，真正探索外面的世界。但这并不一定意味着你应该对此犯傻，或者你必须完全放弃所有逻辑。冒险仍然需要判断力。是的，有些人更有可能冒险，但这并不一定意味着你也应该如此。我真的鼓励你仔细思考：我为什么要这么做？潜在的收益是什么
Of course, I think this podcast and what I've been talking about is very risk-positive. I truly do believe that the most amazing growth will come out of, the periods of greatest discomfort where we really push ourselves and we really explore what's out there. But it doesn't necessarily mean that you have to be silly about it or that you have to completely abandon all logic. Taking a risk still requires judgment. And yes, there are people who are more likely to take risks, but that doesn't necessarily mean that you should. I would really encourage you to think through, why do I want to do this? What is the benefit? that I might receive. And there's this idea, and I don't know where it comes from, but someone
我可能会收到。有一个概念，我不知道它来自哪里，但有人前几天跟我提起过，我必须在这里说出来：当你感觉到灵感、动力和激情在你的内心升起，驱使你采取行动，驱使你说话，驱使你做某事时，虽然这是直觉，但我确实认为这是一个好迹象，表明你准备好跳跃了。但如果你非常紧张，如果从逻辑上讲，你做这件事毫无道理，也许再多想想。也许退一步，沉思一下结果、潜在的结果，
was telling me about it the other day, and I just have to say it here, when you feel that inspiration and that motivation and passion rising within you, compelling you to act, compelling you to speak, compelling you to do something, although it's intuition, I do think it's a good sign that you're ready to take the leap. But if you're very nervous, if logically, it doesn't make sense for you to do this, maybe think about it a little bit more. Maybe sit back, contemplate the outcome, the potential outcomes,
但不要在那个地方花太多时间。就像我说的，正如那项研究所揭示的那样，如果你担心遗憾，如果你担心你的未来，如果你担心你是否会回顾过去并真正怀疑自己并批评你所做出的决定，很有可能你不会。因为那些
but don't spend too much time in that place. Like I said, and like that study revealed, if you're worried about regret, if you're worried about your future, if you're worried about whether you'll look back and really doubt yourself and criticize the decisions that you've made, the chances are that you won't. Because the people who,
经历最多遗憾的人，并不是那些做出决定的人。而是那些没有做出决定的人。我知道这有点像是一个漫无边际的一集，但我真的希望如果你听到了这里，你会喜欢它。这只是最近一直在我的脑海里盘旋的一件事，是我一直在思考的一件事。你知道的，我在我的生活中做出了这个巨大的决定。我真的希望这是一个正确的决定。也许这一集只是我试图说服自己它是正确的，并真正审视冒险和遗憾的概念，并为自己提供我需要的验证。但我真的认为，在我们二十多岁时进行一次非常宝贵的对话。这个十年真是太棒了。我真的相信
experience the most regret, and not those who made the decision. They're those who didn't. I know this was kind of a rambly episode, but I really do hope that if you have listened this far, that you enjoyed it. It was something that's just been really playing on my mind recently, something that I've been thinking about. You know, I've made this massive decision in my life. I really hope that it was the right decision. And maybe this episode was just me trying to convince myself that it was and to really look into the idea of taking risks and regret and provide myself with the validation that I needed. But I do genuinely think that it's an incredibly valuable conversation to have in our 20s. This decade is just so amazing. And I do truly believe that
它是通往如此多的自由、如此多的机会和经验的大门。但你必须准备好接受它。你必须准备好真正抓住这个十年赋予我们和提供给我们的东西。这意味着有时要冒一点险。所以我希望无论谁在听这一集，都能真正启发你去冒险，去做一些非传统的事情，去追随你的梦想、激情和爱好。我只是认为这是我们能做出的最好的决定之一。而且研究也证明了这一点。心理学和这个学科中的许多概念，解释了为什么我们在年轻时在这个年龄做出这些决定是很重要的。所以我只想感谢你的收听。
it's our gateway to so much freedom and so much opportunity and experiences. But you have to be prepared to take it. You have to be prepared to really grasp on to what is afforded us and provided to us in this decade. And that means taking a risk sometimes. So I hope whoever is listening this episode has really inspired you to take a risk, to do something unconventional, to follow your dreams and your passions and your hobbies. I just think it's one of the best decisions that we can make. And the studies kind of prove it as well. so many of the ideas in psychology and in this discipline, explain why it's important that we make these decisions when we're young at this age. So I just want to thank you for listening.
感谢你和我一起经历这段旅程。我还想说，如果没有你们——我的听众的支持，这一切都是不可能的。我能走到这一步简直太疯狂了。我能够一直做我最喜欢的事情，这真是太疯狂、太野蛮了。我真的非常喜欢它。我认为心理学中有如此多有价值的信息，我们可以作为二十多岁的朋友一起分享和探索。所以我要感谢你们让我能够追求这个梦想。这真的、真的是令人难以置信的。我想任何词语都无法充分表达我有多么感激。
Thank you for coming along this ride with me. I also want to say none of this would be possible without the support of you, my listeners. It's just insane to me that I've gotten to this point. It's so crazy and wild that I'm able to do the thing that I love most all the time. And I do genuinely love it. I think there is so much valuable information in psychology that we can share and explore as fellow 20-year-olds. So I want to say thank you for enabling me to be able to pursue this. It's just, it really is mind-blowing. I don't think words could ever properly capture how grateful I am.
如果你确实喜欢这一集，如果你喜欢这个节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，并与朋友分享。也许你的朋友正经历一段犹豫不决的时期，他们需要决定是否走那条人迹罕至的路。所以分享给他们吧。也许他们会从中受益。如果你想保持联系，如果你想参与到这个社区中来，请随时关注我们的那个心理学播客（that psychology podcast）。给我发消息。如果你有任何节目建议，保持联系。非常欢迎你们加入。
And if you did enjoy this episode, if you enjoyed this show, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, and share it with a friend. Maybe your friend is going through a period of indecision where they need to decide whether to take the road less traveled. So share it with them. Maybe they would benefit. And if you want to stay connected, if you want to be involved in the community, please feel free to follow us at that. psychology podcast. Message me. If you have any episode suggestions, just stay in touch. It would be lovely to have you over there.
你将是第一个知道新节目何时发布、我们本周在谈论什么、周边商品何时发布以及所有这些美妙事情的人。所以再次，我只想说，对于你们所有的支持，我是多么感激。我真的无法用言语表达。我太高兴了。非常感谢你们。希望下周还能看到你们回来收听
You'll be the first to know when new episodes are out, what we're talking about this week, when merchandise is released, and all of those fabulous things. So once again, I just want to say how grateful I am for all of your support. I really, I can't put it into words. I'm so happy. So thank you so much. And I hope to see you back again next week. for another episode.
另一集节目。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《硬核学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全却又极其坦诚的对话，而你正在与一位持证专业人士一起交流
who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio
他深知自己在做什么。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须这样做。请在AHA广播电台
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mianini.
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方收听《硬核学习》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾对某人的这份特定检测报告做过两次手脚，对吗？我只对检测动过一次手脚。数以万计的互联网侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·格莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·米亚尼尼（Michael Mianini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《被爱捕获》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被爱捕获》播客。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是数字2开头的百分之二。
On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。